se requiere que los estudiantes de
primer año de una gran universidad vivan
en una de las 24 residencias disponibles
del campus después de su primer año los
estudiantes tienen la opción de vivir
fuera del campus pero muchos eligen
seguir viviendo en esas residencias este
la supervisa 12 de las resistencias del
campus su equipo de trabajo realizó una
encuesta a una muestra aleatoria simple
grande de estudiantes de primer año que
viven en esas 12 residencias
universitarias sobre qué tan satisfechos
están en general convivir en el campus
para que población
stella puede generalizar con seguridad
los resultados de la encuesta
ok pausa el vídeo e intenta encontrar la
respuesta bueno
stella tomó una muestra aleatoria simple
grande de estudiantes de primer año
entonces veamos el inciso a solo para
los estudiantes que fueron encuestados
no es una muestra de la teoría simple y
es una muestra grande por lo que debe de
ser indicativa de todos los estudiantes
de primer aire podemos generalizar más
que simplemente hacer proposiciones solo
acerca de los estudiantes encuestados
por lo tanto voy a descartar esta opción
inciso b para todos los estudiantes de
primer año que viven en esas 12
residencias si está me parece la opción
correcta ya que no podemos generalizar
para los estudiantes que no vivan en
esas residencias tal vez este la
supervisa a las mejores 12 residencias o
las peores 12 residencias o tal vez las
12 residencias más cercanas
campus o las 12 residencias más lejanas
al campus si ese fuera el caso no
podríamos generalizar más allá de esas
residencias que supervisa por lo tanto
si sólo podemos generalizar para
estudiantes que vivan en estas 12
residencias
inciso c para todos los estudiantes sean
o no de primer año que viven en esas 12
residencias el problema que le veo a
este inciso es que los estudiantes de
segundo o tercer año podrían tener una
perspectiva diferente incluso si viven
en esas 12 residencias como este la
encuesta a una muestra aleatoria simple
grande de estudiantes de primer año
entonces no se hizo una muestra
aleatoria simple grande de todos los
estudiantes de esas 12 residencias por
lo tanto podemos cancelar esta opción
inciso d para todos los estudiantes de
primer año de toda la universidad pero
no para los de años posteriores bueno
este es y eso no es correcto porque
habría estudiantes de primer año que
vivirían fuera de esas 12 residencias y
como ya hemos mencionado las residencias
que supervisa este la pueden ser o no
indicativas de donde viven todos los
estudiantes de primer año en la
universidad así que también voy a
cancelar este
y ya está hemos acabado y nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo